good ideas for movies turn up in all
kinds of places a children's table and
an offbeat love story found in the
secondhand bookshop were just two of the
sources that inspired the artists by
next writing Award nominees for Best
Screenplay based on material previously
produced or published are William
Broyles jr. and Aaron art for Apollo 13
based on the book lost moon by Jim
Lovell Jeffrey CUDA George Miller and
Chris Newman for babe based on the book
the Sheep pig by dick King Smith Mike
figures for leaving Las Vegas based on
the novel by John O'Brien
and a pavilion Oh michael radford
furious Scarpelli Giacomin Scarpelli
massima Troisi for the postman the
pastina based on the novel burning
patients pan tony's got him Etta emma
thompson for the Sense and Sensibility
adapted from the novel by Jane Austen
and you asked of pests screenplay
adaptation is awarded to Emma Thompson
I don't really know how to thank the
Academy for this um and if I try we'll
be here till Christmas so I better get
on before I came I went to visit Jane
Austen's grave in when she's a cathedral
to pay my respects you know and tell her
about the groceries and I don't know how
she would react to an evening like this
but I do hope I do hope she knows how
big she is in Uruguay profound thanks to
Columbia Pictures in the lovely forms of
Lisa Henson Gareth Wigan and mark Canton
for hiring a first-time writer
- James Shamus for his rare intelligence
- Sydney [ __ ] for asking all the
right questions like why couldn't these
women go out and get a job why indeed um
- - the cast and crew for being
impeccable - my friend and my teacher
Lindsay Duran for being the single most
frustrating reason why I can't claim all
the credit for myself and finally I
would like with your permission to
dedicate this Oscar to our director
Angley and wherever you are this is for
you